all right guys
bang bang i've got suna here super
excited about this uh thanks so much for
taking the time to do it
thanks for having me for sure so uh for
like the 10 people on crypto twitter who
don't know who you are let's start with
the with your background
um where did you grow up and what did
you do before you got to uh san
francisco and technology
yeah sure um you know i got into bitcoin
when i was in college
i went to university of michigan i was
part of the school of engineering there
and you know all of us were on reddit
way too often
um you know at the time bitcoin and dosh
klein were the biggest memes and
at the time the biggest conversation we
had around it was you know whether or
not
the government would let bitcoin happen
and
uh it was incredibly early um you know
most folks weren't going into the
cryptocurrency industry we went on to
join startups
i did that i joined alliation it was
just closed at series a
it's a data cataloging startup and so
it's pretty similar to blockchain
actually because you get transparency
into how
data transforms who's doing what and so
i think just thematically that's always
been something important to me is
integrity of information
and democratizing access to it we scaled
the company out
quite well you know the serie c was just
co-led by salesforce and sapphire
ventures
and at the time um i was doing election
by day and crypto by night
um i was helping a lot of folks get set
up with wallets
and learn you know who were the
followers that they should focus on
you know i think at the time it was only
coindesk and reddit
that really gave anybody crypto
information of course there are a lot
more resources now
but i set out to be this source of truth
for
crypto and like high quality information
in the space and we grew pretty
organically to
over you know 16 000 readers i did you
know no marketing
because i wanted it to stay high signal
in terms of who's part of the community
and what they were building
and we just had such great people come
through
like lolly launched on token daily
compound
just a really great crew of um super
ambitious builders
got it and so in the beginning when uh
you started toking daily
was it more focused on kind of filtering
and curating
other people's work or were you guys
trying to actually create more original
content yourselves
so we were doing more curation and so we
started as a newsletter
and a platform for launching startups
and that's why you know lolly had
launched in compound launch and
you know plethora of others and we also
curated
um you know thought pieces around the
space and other updates
around different protocols we started
then doing deep dives
into different tokens and different
projects and telling people what the
trade-offs were we were very
sensitive to and intentionally uh you
know did not
classify things into binary good or bad
we would just illustrate trade
offs like here's the vision that someone
is after here the trade-offs we foresee
uh will allow you to moralize for
yourself and i think that you know the
best
curators and um you know hubs of
information
allow the reader to you know get all the
facts and make those decisions for
themselves
that's a uh a very rare idea these days
i think there's a lot of opinions
floating around
um and then so what kind of has evolved
since then right so that's kind of how
you guys started what does token daily
look like
today yeah so you know we saw a lot of
great
um entrepreneurs super early on and we
were helping them with distribution
in terms of you know the newsletter and
their platform for launching
um you know helped a lot of great
companies source talent that came in
through the token daily community
we acted as sounding boards for um a lot
of
entrepreneurs that wanted advice or
feedback in terms of the roadmap and
what we were seeing
and so i wanted to meaningfully help you
know outside of
you know just providing a community and
a lot of these resources and also
align incentives and put capital behind
these great founders that we think
should have a chance
and really you know um bring their
projects to life so
we sent out bolt capital and that's the
venture arm and the community arm is
token daily
and you know we're just backing really
great
founders from the token daily community
that are building pretty cool ideas
and we you know we can jump into the
thesis
if you'd like but you know our actual
community comes in from
a slew of different places so we have
you know super ambitious engineers from
uh amazon and google and facebook but we
also have you know repeat founders that
we're increasingly seeing now
folks have sold their companies to
microsoft or docker or you know
successfully exited and we are
um you know backing them now in fact i
actually was taking a step back and i
want to know if you
similarly think this i was realizing
that the wave of entrepreneurs
that come about are different with each
bull run so i think the first
wave was kind of like the entrepreneurs
that had nothing to lose they were super
fringe they were building mining
companies
um you know even though a lot of them
had unsavory interests it was you know
just the thing to do and then the second
wave were
um really ambitious engineers at these
bigger companies and of course
the um canonical example being the
coinbase with reinhardt strong being at
airbnb
then and this third wave are repeat
entrepreneurs
who have successfully exited or safely
landed a company
and that are now building in crypto and
i think more importantly is that these
are
these are entrepreneurs that didn't
necessarily build a company
in crypto before and had a successful
exit and are now looking into the crypto
space and thinking
there's something here in terms of users
in terms of volume locked up
in terms of um you know use cases yeah i
definitely think that there's
uh kind of waves as you described the
other thing that's really interesting to
me
is how people can kind of transition
between those right so you may get an
engineer who when they're starting their
first company
is just a engineer who's excited and
has kind of really powerful ideas and
they go and they build well
by the time that three four five years
goes by
and they want to start something else
like by nature they have now
transitioned into the repeat
entrepreneur bucket right so it's
actually the same person
it's just that over time they're able to
gain more experience and so you're
starting i think to see
now a couple of people who have started
their second or third company
uh within crypto and if you look at
their journey
like the first company they started they
were actually considered you know one of
those other two groups
and so what i think it gives us um kind
of excitement about is like you want to
find those people who
they just continue to have hit after hit
after hit uh
and they really really understand the
space and you see this outside of crypto
as well right and there's all kinds of
people who just
it's like you know i won't name names
but there's cert literally people i'm
like i think that's the third time
they're building that company
like they built it they sold it they
built it again they sold to somebody
else and like
it's like basically the same company
they're building a third time which is
good for them but they just really
understand something
uh and are quite successful with it
totally
yeah i think the lesson there is always
invest in stuart butterfield starting a
gaming company and you might end up with
a slew of other companies that do
incredibly well
yeah i think that's a great point what
um what
tell me more about volt capital so
obviously you guys uh it sounds like are
kind of
leveraging early access um and kind of
uh information there but what's the
thesis kind of have you guys constructed
that and what's the plan moving forward
right so volt capital like you said is a
community driven
firm we spent years investing in and
building out a
pretty robust community of super
brilliant entrepreneurs and builders
that are
looking to do their next thing in terms
of our thesis
it's pretty contrarian for the space but
i would say pretty unsexy in terms of
traditional investing where
you know we are investing in companies
with pretty traditional business models
that are leveraging digital assets so
these are the companies that i believe
are going to help crypto cross the chasm
uh there are three
directional bets this falls under so the
first one is
end user infrastructure and that's not
to be confused with you know developer
infrastructure these are end user facing
these are primarily top of the stack
they look like you know
data and analytics tooling they look
like uh identity solutions
like our recent investment in magic and
the second directional bet we're taking
is in digital asset intermediaries so
these are the on and off ramps that
you're seeing around the world
a recent investment we made here is
value which is of course servicing latin
america and allowing folks to
pretty much access what looks like fiat
on the front end
but you know charged by bitcoin back end
just instead of ach or swift
and then the last bucket which you know
uh is i guess
more of the moonshots or the you know it
gives us a little bit of more flexible
mandate is uh open finance applications
and
these are generally anything that carves
out
a traditional asset intermediary and one
example here that was uh pretty fun
that i scouted uh earlier on in my
career was a matrix league and this is
a company that's building the robin hood
layer on top of esports
and allowing you know these incredibly
loyal esports fans to go from passive
observers of tournaments to active
participants
so that's generally what we focus on i
think the space is
still incredibly early even though it's
been said 100 times
and if you look empirically to
companies that did well in these super
early internet days
you know you're looking at oracle or
bloomberg terminal um
you know products and solutions look
like that and they weren't internet
native but they became
more valuable as more people came online
and so that's what we're looking for
got it and so uh the first two i think
are pretty self-explanatory right but on
that third one open finance
um there's uh a little bit of
clarification i think that
uh hasn't been done across people
working in that space and so
i've previously obviously as long as
everyone else heard
decentralized finance right which is
literally the decentralization of the
services
uh i personally have used the
terminology automated finance
where some of automated finance is
decentralized some of it's not you're
using the term open
finance uh maybe just kind of elaborate
a little bit like open finance does that
include
automation does that include
decentralization is it something
completely different like how do you
think those three terms
uh maybe they're just redundant or maybe
they're actually talking about different
things there
yeah i view it as open finance being the
top and
automated finance as well decentralized
finance you know
falling underneath that i think with g5
the risk you run is that many folks
think protocols and
we are not you know we are not trading
we are not active traders
and uh you know with automated finance i
think that
that is more so
uh traditional finance or you know what
some people classify as web 2.0
um and so i think open finance then
allows you to group both of those
underneath that and you know
speaking of in terms of protocols
we do have a staking arm called td labs
uh you may have noticed that we are in
the top
10 or 11 validator is now on sello and
you know the focus of the fund
is not to invest in tokens
but we do like to run scripts and
understand
protocols better and generate insights
that way um
it's just a complete no-brainer we do it
you know outside the nine-to-five and
are still doing incredibly well in terms
of optimization so
very cool and then in terms of um
the fund itself like you guys are
obviously taking um
a very different approach than let's say
anyone who's buying the liquid protocols
or
uh or trading what type of investors do
you feel like
uh you guys kind of match up nicely with
right so take somebody like
us who's doing kind of traditional
venture capital very heavy
infrastructure that's pretty much it
uh that lends itself for the
institutional world for you guys
is there a certain lp group that you
feel like is a good fit or is it more of
um kind of you're really working across
the spectrum
yeah there's a mix uh i'm finding that
more and more
uh you know these larger funds are
realizing
that it's probably more judicious to
diversify into
equity and liquid positions
and so uh and that wasn't the case
before
uh when i had to you know draw a
similarity between us
and other funds it would always have to
be outside of crypto because
most people were taking advantage
opportunistically of you know uh
speculative activity
and oftentimes business being traders to
be frank
um but you know that's changed that's
changed since and a lot more funds are
now are looking at equity companies and
looking at fixed shovels and looking at
the companies that
we generally invest in so i would say
it's across the spectrum at this point
got it and then um let's back away from
crypto for a second and obviously
there's all this chaos going on in the
world
uh one being coveted 19 but also
some of the economic shocks um that have
been happening
uh let's start with covet 19 like what
have you guys seen
on the ground at the very earliest
stages of these companies being formed
how has that impacted the entrepreneurs
and the things that they're building
yeah that's the thing is it hasn't and
i'm glad you distinguish
between earlier companies and later
companies uh
you know early stage investing is
trucking along as usual
and if anything you know um earlier
companies are absorbing
uh you know market prices are probably
changing
so rounds are probably cheaper uh we've
seen
you know terms that are you know better
for obviously the investors
uh but you know for companies that can
continue doing well
uh they're holding off even you know if
they're profitable or their cash flow
positive and they're waiting out the
market and then we'll go
and you know raise the healthy uh series
a or b
you know down the line instead it's just
not worth it to them to sacrifice those
terms
for seed extensions or whatnot um but
you know i think later stage investing
is where you're seeing
a lot of the change because
a few things are happening one a lot of
these larger uh
funds are turning inward and making sure
their companies who are you know close
to successfully exiting
have runway to get there and what you're
finding ironically is that a lot of
these larger companies that were already
incredibly profitable um were going to
co-spy on profitability which is a great
thing
to coast on uh in you know regular
markets but they didn't have much
in the way of runway in terms of vc
funding because they weren't going to
rely on that they
you know probably thought they were
going to ipo and so they have to do
emergency rounds now and get more runway
bc funding so you're seeing some
interesting things there where all these
bigger companies had
you know presumably achieved escape
velocity or were well on their way to
ipos actually raising
uh you know emergency uh funding grounds
it's the uh it's the old analogy of like
building the plane while in midair
uh literally finding out that you don't
have some of the parts right and say hey
we really need some help um
and then on the economic side uh one of
the big things is
you know i can see you say this is like
the number one debate in finance right
now
uh inflationary or deflationary
environment
in the short term and inflationary
versus deflationary
environment of the long term uh where
one do you come out on that
and two how do you think that affects
the market
yeah it's a great question and
definitely the question of the
i think the year um you know just from
an economic standpoint
i mean you're looking at 20 to 30
unemployment uh
you know retail is the lowest retail
spending has been the lowest it's ever
been on record
um a factory output i think hasn't been
this low since world war ii
um you know there have been local
government
state and local government shortfalls
travel has been decimated
and you know the snp
is slightly down if not up right and so
you know
we're obviously saying massive spending
uh the fed has expanded its balance
sheet you know
9 trillion plus and so what that tells
me
is for those that are familiar with the
cantelon effect is
a lot of this just hasn't been
circulated into the economy we haven't
had you know prices reflect
um this fresh supply and it may very
well just be absorbed
um and you know show no changes like
japan has been printing forever and
they're still in
deflationary stagnation and the reason
is because
even though we try to illustrate
economics
through you know various equations like
mv
equals pq we can't apply
physics equations to the economy it is
not the problem with economics that
tries to present
itself as physics is that there are
often many solutions to market problems
and the inverse is also true one
solution can work for a variety of
different markets
and the reason is because the
relationship between
um you know different parties within the
market are not
readily apparent or understood
and so you see a lot of exotic um you
know derivatives you see a lot of
interesting
you know reshuffling of you know balance
sheets and just
a lot of things that are not really
apparent so to think that it's going to
be a seesaw where you have
one movement cause something else on the
other end i think is naive
at best if not you know ignorant uh but
there are speculations that we can make
in terms of what will happen short term
versus long term
short term prices are going down people
aren't employed
they can't spend even if you're giving
them a 1200 check
for a month it's not going to stimulate
the economy the way you think it's going
to
and so that is of course what we know is
deflationary and as a deflationary
environment
and you know we haven't applied this to
bitcoin just yet but to give the bitcoin
angle to this
you know if prices are going lower and
like you know you can
go to hawaii for 50 dollars and i'm
exaggerating of course
but you know the us dollar is stronger
your purchasing power goes up in these
environments right and so
bitcoin's narrative as a store of value
all of a sudden
is not as enticing but what we
foresee is that you know a lot of the
uh parenting that we're doing now is
going to have ramifications down the
line these things compound
and that's when bitcoin becomes you know
a more attractive
uh asset class at least in the u.s now
this isn't the case for sovereign for
weak sovereign borrowers
that are you know have their debt
denominated in u.s currencies
um you know who have to stimulate their
uh economy
in order to just maintain supply chains
and as a consequence
experience hyperinflation this is
happening now regardless of whether or
not the us is going through a
deflationary
um you know period and what are they
going to do rely on swap lines so they
don't even have a
reserve currency like it's absurd so i'm
just happy that you know bitcoin at
least gives
a lot of these folks the ability to exit
or you know reset
yeah one of the things that um i think
people are quickly waking up to
that uh cracks me up is well there
really is two things so one is stock
market obviously is completely
dislocated from any economic reality
uh and a lot of that has to the central
bank actions but two is uh home prices
so i i did a recent kind of dive down
the rabbit hole
uh and exactly what you described right
you would imagine that hey there's this
economic shock people lose their jobs
there's all these issues
home prices will come down people want
liquidity you know yadda yadda whatever
the
the kind of theory is but actually what
you see is because the federal reserve
acted so quickly and they dropped rates
now you have cheap capital flooding the
market everyone and their mom is
literally borrowing money and trying to
buy homes and so
you see a house go on the market it's
got you know five bids in 72 hours and
people are overpaying for even what the
asking price was and
you're just like okay in hindsight that
makes sense
if you would have asked me this you know
back in january i would have told you
there's very little chance of that
happening
and so it's kind of just it's such a
complex thing
that i think to your point a single
equation is just makes it almost nearly
impossible to actually evaluate what's
going to happen right
absolutely yeah i completely agree with
that if people become pretty irrational
um you know they're just things you
can't anticipate or you'll have
an idea of what will happen going in um
or even ideas that seem nonsensical at
the time like v-shape recovery everyone
laughed at and all of a sudden people
are taking seriously so
i i think someone had tweeted something
to the effect of you know
if there's one thing that's true about
the market is it all it will always find
a way to make you look dumb or something
to the effect of that the
you know i i've said this before but
people are waking up to the fact that
you know stock market is divorced from
the economy is divorced for money
yeah and i guess part of that is uh
do you believe that that will be true or
is true uh
in crypto right so kind of what is there
kind of a dislocation between
uh the prices of various assets and
actually the quote-unquote fundamentals
right so if you
bitcoin being the easiest example all of
the things that somebody would look at
as kind of the fundamentals of bitcoin
that drive value
do you see um kind of that dislocation
seeping into the crypto markets as well
or do you feel like
uh it's somewhat sheltered or insulated
from that
you know the hope and the answer you'd
want to say is that
they would be tied together and
everything would make sense and there
wouldn't be room
for you know a forward-looking market
versus
the underlying economic engine and
that's just not the case and we see that
and the reason that's not the case is
because
there are derivatives being built on top
of
this crypto system and that's you know
frankly what always happens you know
since the beginning of stock market
since the beginning of
you know currency people find what
creative ways to
um you know open up options for
different ways of making money for
different ways of leveraging for
you know vetting and so you know we're
seeing a lot of d5 projects uh
create derivatives and create different
ways of lending and borrowing
um i the difference though this time is
that there's transparency around it
there's more transparency uh you know
there isn't this double spend
problem and so you know it's
it's fine for markets to look forward
it's just not fine
for there to be you know quite literally
white-collar
crimes in terms of what's going on with
the balance sheet in terms of what's
going on
with um you know printing and not and
you know
i consider personally think it's you
know um uh
a financial um a horrible decision which
is why with bitcoin but
you know um some people think it's what
you have to do at the time but
i think it's a crime to be developed
developing devaluing a currency
at this rate um anyway so in terms of
d5 though and in terms of these
derivatives being built it's actually
this uptick in activity around that is
why we launched the chicago d5 alliance
recently
and volk capital launched that alongside
jump trading which is the largest um
you know partner for uh robin hood or i
believe the only
uh for robin hood crypto and
um you know they're looking at d5 and
they think it's interesting
and you know they're increasingly seeing
you know stable coins enter
um yeah effects markets they're saying
that that's increasingly the payment
rail through which money flows around
different countries
and we also launched this alongside um
cumberland drw
cmt digital and a few others and you
know
the problem that we find with a lot of
these defy projects is it's kind of a
cold start
problem where d5 projects are looking
for liquidity
and market makers want to go where
there's already volume so then the
question is
you know how do you get partners who
will take that leap of faith with you
and convince them that you know sure
short term upside probably isn't here
yet
but you're you know playing the long
game and going to capitalize on more of
this like long-term upside and so
i think it's pretty positive that a lot
of these traditional
firms are looking to defy as
um you know an interesting way for
a lot of um you know traditional finance
to be
done in a system where it's more
accessible to everybody
where you're able to um access the same
types of
um crediting system loaning system
borrowing whatever uh across different
countries
without the need to have you know a bank
and so when you see those large firms
right everyone from jump training you
described to literally we saw a filing
where renaissance technology wants to
kind of trade bitcoin whatever they're
going to do
what do you feel like is the big
obstacle because it feels like
in many cases this is one of the things
that they're doing
right so um it's a small portion of
their overall capital base they're
intrigued by it they're dipping their
toe in the water they're testing they're
learning they're doing all that stuff
how do we get them from kind of that
dipping their toe
into an area where it's 20 30 50 percent
of the assets
under management that they're actually
participating in the ecosystem
similar to what they do in other markets
right the stock market or whatever there
right that's an excellent question and
there are a few reasons
one headline risk to technical
ease and just where we are technically
in terms of user experience
is not quite there yet and the amount of
resources you need to
dedicate in order to integrate these
products and to be able to
you know get engineers up to speed um
oftentimes is just
a sunk cost for a lot of these firms
that frankly don't understand it at this
point
um and then you know thirdly is any
regulatory risk that may come with it
and these things are not new to crypto
these are
problems with any you know paradigm
shift there are a million reasons why
you know
certain companies wouldn't you know
operate with the internet or use https
when
that was becoming you know privacy
pressuring protocol for
e-commerce websites and you know it's
just
these are going to in hindsight will be
problems
that will almost seem negligible or
trivial but seem big right now because
we're tackling them
once we get those um you know nailed i
think that a lot more are going to be
coming in and honestly i think it's
going to be driven by user demand so
we're going to have more of a bottom-up
type of pressure uh you know the more
people that use it
the larger it gets the harder it is to
ignore
yeah and i guess one of the things um
i've been really interested in
is uh kind of this element of trust so
especially in like the decentralized
world where uh there's
it's really supposed to be kind of
trustless uh if you're a
large asset manager you still have to
have some level of trust whether it's in
the protocol whether it's in the
developers behind it
it's the uh the company that maybe that
you're going through whatever it is
uh to go put you know let's say hundreds
of millions or billions of dollars
at stake uh that is very different than
you know paul tudor jones i think was a
great example he put two percent of
assets for one and a half percent of
assets
it's still like 4-500 million bucks
really like it was still a big big
number
it's not one thing to go and just get
exposure whether he does it through the
options market or he actually buys and
puts it in custody
that's kind of like the safest most
conservative thing to do in the space
but if you want to go put you know even
half a billion dollars to work
in d5 i just don't know if that's
possible yet right
and so kind of how do you think through
um is it something where it just takes
time
is it something where uh we need kind of
the courageous
you know asset management firm that's
the first through the door and they're
the ones who
who risk it all and put you know a big
sum of money in like like how does that
kind of sequentially play out in your
opinion
yeah it's many things um you know all of
the above
the you know the first part is like look
it's like what eight billion locked up
in stable coins right now
um like sitting on the sidelines these
are still pretty small numbers and so
putting in 500 million to a billion is a
large chunk of money
just relative to where the space is at
it's time but it's also intention
what you need are um you know
high net worth uh individuals and
companies and firms
that you know for them to take the sleep
of faith and to actually engage with
you know these emerging crypto systems
for it to be a rounding error for them
if they're wrong and for it to be career
defining if they're right
but the thing is that a lot of people
you know that are up and coming or
emerging
the ones that are really enticed by this
may not be wanting to take
that um career risk because you know if
they're right
they're really right and if they're
wrong um you know the market isn't
kind it punishes uh you know people for
taking uh
chances early on in their careers so
what you need are more established
people thinking
look this is clearly what millennials
are into is clearly where gen z is going
into i don't think you know the future
of finance is always going to be chase
jp morgan and visa
so i i definitely agree with you on that
um somebody said something to me
recently
and i can't get it out of my head which
is that bitcoin is actually hurting
defy and i asked them to kind of
elaborate on it and what they meant
was uh that kind of career defining move
right that asymmetric upside if you will
uh the people who are seeking that and
convince that that exists in
in the larger crypto blockchain
ecosystem what they end up doing is they
just buy bitcoin
right and that's kind of like the really
risky thing that they do
when you then go talk to people who are
obviously building this stuff operating
in the ecosystem they're like bitcoins
like the conservative boring thing
right like that like that thesis is so
boring compared to i think what you and
i are talking about
and so how do you think that happens
like do we actually need to see
um these folks who are at traditional
firms leave and go start their own kind
of crypto focused firms
or do you feel like we will actually see
d5
seep into whether it's through market
making lending you know
kind of the types of businesses that
they understand just in this new
ecosystem
right that's a really good question so
what will
likely happen is you know so so one
the reason that you see this dichotomy
in terms of people within the space
thinking bitcoin is the old or
conservative story we'll select parties
thinking that
and you know folks on the outside
thinking bitcoin is super high risk and
very like emerging
right now is just simply you know
information velocity and information
asymmetry of course
so you know being into it day in day out
you're more sensitive to changes
on the outside it seems like a monolith
and as though it hasn't changed really
at all uh in terms of how we get people
in look
uh the thing is is you know the future
goes from being
incredibly um you know uh seemingly
impossible to be inevitable
and similar to the companies that missed
out on you know early internet days
similar to you know blockbuster making
fun of netflix
i mean these people just get left behind
and the ones that do take the risk in
terms of starting their own firms
in terms of integrating with crypto
companies and helping them get their
leg to get you know uh hit escape
velocity or to get you know off the
ground
are the ones they're gonna stay at the
forefront of
um you know the space in the future of
finance and what looks like increasingly
it will be the future of the internet
and so it's going to be a mix with most
things
that start out organically like this
it's going to be bottoms up
it's going to be a lot of users
demanding it it's going to be
nimble and smaller companies and this
goes back to the innovator's dilemma
being able to sense that integrate it
expand users and then have incumbents
you know cave to the pressure
if it's not too late so that brings me
to
somebody like square right which i think
is probably the only
i'll call it a traditional technology
company which which is uh somewhat of a
slight by accident
towards them because they're definitely
not traditional but they have
chosen to go all in on bitcoin right and
kind of the
what i would consider more like the
bitcoin ethos and what you and i would
believe is like okay
that is quote-unquote the right way to
do something
versus we've seen lots of other
technology companies or even in the
finance world they want to create their
own tokens they want to do all kind of
all this other stuff
which is really kind of the
corporatization of
this technology this space does that
seep in to other people or is it really
like a hey you need a jack dorsey
running it and unless the leader buys in
you'll just never see these other
companies
um kind of jump in and they'll actually
get disrupted so going towards your like
blockbuster
example like literally the large banks
they'll just never
kind of get in uh through the open
protocols and things like that and they
end up getting disrupted
yeah um it could be a mix of them it
actually reminds me of
you know the open source versus closed
source wars uh
you know in the early uh whatever in the
early 90s and you know
mid 90s and you know microsoft
versus um a lot of these other open
source projects that wanted to keep
things open source and not corporatize
them
there are different speeds and different
flavors that people have and you might
end up with
bifurcated systems where you know some
people prefer iphones some people prefer
androids and there are different um you
know
ways they integrate new technology and
different implementations
and you know there's another story where
it could just seamlessly
charge the back end of a lot of products
and we don't even notice the difference
as users but you know folks that were
too slow to you know really leverage and
harness that technology
just become you know names in history
that you don't really remember
yeah yeah and then uh you've got a very
interesting thesis on
africa um maybe talk through just like
what's the interest there and kind of
how does that play out
yeah so i recently did an essay
on just the potential of crypto in
africa
um i think specifically the essay was
titled you know why
africa is poised to be the next hub for
crypto development
and i do think it's massively
underlooked uh and
and you know i don't think real people
really understand how
huge these tailwinds are the most common
story is yes there's rapid inflation
historically
zimbabwe nigeria now a select
few other countries are experiencing
rapid inflation
um and you know there's also the
narrative that's also pretty commonly
known
is that this is a mobile first continent
so they got to skip the legacy
infrastructure like landlines
and are instead jumping into mobile
first types of behaviors and the second
or third most popular thing they do on
their phones is payments
but the kicker and the part that really
shocks people they don't think they
really fully understand is that the
average age
on the continent of africa the average
age of the population is 19
years old and so the imf extrapolated
this out and just based
on you know birth and death rates for
countries around the world
by 2035 there will be more
people joining the workforce from africa
than the rest of the world
combined so it's really important
to think about and you know learn what
are what's that half of the population
thinking about
building learning like what are they
doing with their time
and what do they spend their time on and
so that's really important in terms of
trying to
figure out where the future is headed in
terms of mobile payments and fintech
fintech and crypto
are some of the largest uh investments
that foreign investors make
in you know african uh countries and so
you know i think that it's incredibly
important to look at the behaviors there
the companies there
there's a great company called bike
lines and they provide a
on-ramp off-ramp um for crypto and
they're essentially bringing this
pretty informal economy and making it
more formal
they're uh you know matching parties uh
in terms of you know
getting folks to switch from fiat to
bitcoin and
i think they're doing excellent work and
they became you know
they're scaling really well i've been
really impressed with their growth got
it
and so as part of this
africa across the continent has
mainly kind of leap-frogged i think u.s
let's say in mobile payments right or
kind of mobile finance uh they went from
having no
access to banking at all to today you
know things like mp6 extra
are are well documented do you feel like
um there's this natural blending between
crypto
uh and that type of innovation that
they've already seen
or is this a separate thing right
because in the us right now
it's pretty separated there's very few
things like a cache app where you can do
both
it's either like i've got a mobile you
know application that
can do crypto and i've got one that does
my traditional banking i think people
are trying to close that gap
but in africa is that the same type of
work or is this much more kind of
organic and
people just have one app on their phone
and it does everything
right that's that's also a really great
question so the way i view it is
i think this is an incredibly poignant
line um you know
a lot of people view crypto as the last
leg
of fintech so you've been able to
unbundle all of these financial services
that banks traditionally did
into you know niche products and
solutions and the last unbundling
is you know uh monetary uh transmission
essentially like separating the state
from
money and it doesn't make sense as much
when you're in the us
and you can reliably um you know use the
dollar
versus places where there is rampant
hyperinflation
and then fintech and crypto i think uh
you know converge
to one whereas in other countries
that don't you know suffer from this
rapid hyperinflation
it doesn't make as much sense or there
are alternatives and so
when we see that you know even in
behaviors it's largely speculative in
the us which is fine
most technologies need to be speculative
similar to early internet in order to
have people look up from what they're
doing and realize that there's something
going on here and that they could get in
and i'm not gonna miss anything so this
inducing fomo is nothing new and
actually needed for any you know new
technological innovation
but then uh you know looking at even i
mean i'm lebanese my entire family is
lebanese my parents did not understand
this until
uh the lira lost its peg to the stock to
the dollar and it used to be 1500 lira's
equals a dollar and it was that way for
um i believe decades and you know just
last week
7 000 liras now equals a dollar and the
first sex i got were my parents saying
we finally get this bitcoin thing
we understand what this means and so you
know they're the first
folks that experience hyperinflation are
the first to understand it uh
on a really visceral level uh and and
you know
won't distinguish fintech from crypto
because it's one of the same it's their
finances
yeah so i didn't know that you were
lebanese uh i got a million questions
um so feel free to kind of answer what
you want what you don't but
uh explain that a little bit more
because i think that
part of my perspective and again this is
coming from
a guy who's lived in the united states
his whole life is uh
most people in a country where the
currency is failing so it hasn't kind of
fully you know broken for them but but
it's just beginning to fail and you're
starting to see that that high level of
inflation
they probably don't understand finance
they don't understand monetary policy
all they know is that hey groceries are
getting more expensive and i feel like
i'm losing part of my my savings right
and i just can't buy things
is that accurate or do you feel like uh
as they're seeing prices rise and
and there's the community talking about
it they actually get up to speed very
quickly on monetary policy and finance
oh 100 like lebanese people are like
they're incredibly smart lebanese people
the civilians
the bank's actions do not reflect what
the civilians know they are very well
aware of the fact
that their um monetary policy is
bullocks and they're well aware
that um you know this
to put it in context they are being paid
in lira their salaries are being paid in
lira which is you know rapidly declining
against the us dollar and they are
forced to pay
for food and merchandise with usd
and they understand that because they're
they probably understand that better
than we do because they're seeing it day
to day
um you know you get to the point where
there are atms
in lebanon and these are you know
anecdotes of course um
uh that don't have cash and you open
them up there's no cash that you can
actually extract from them and you're
realizing and the stories behind that is
that
people are taking greenbacks and going
to the border of turkey and syria and
selling them at a premium
it's so valuable to them and they
understand that it's um you know
monitoring fiscal decisions and that's
probably why they you know are doing
things like if you've seen you know
the coverage of protests burning banks
it's because they understand the root of
their problems
and they want to opt out the problem is
and i've had many texts come in
with people asking me how to convert
their wealth a little that they do have
into bitcoin um in lebanon and the
problem is a lot of these services are
geo blocked in lebanon
and so even if you do access something
like local bitcoins you'll probably have
two sellers
they're selling bitcoin at egregious
premiums and you know the question is
what are the services they can use and
you know i've directed folks to total
hotel and bisque but
it's different when there's you know
support in your language and it's
incredibly seamless to use and you have
education around it
and so that's something that i think
should be
rapidly explored because people are
really smart and they know that's
probably better than we do yeah
what i read that was really interesting
about lebanon specifically is people
could go
and we've seen capital controls before
in other countries where they basically
say hey you can only withdraw
x number of uh the currency right so
whether it's 500
worth thousand dollars worth whatever i
think people are kind of used to that
uh but the thing that was really
interesting is that they would not let
you withdraw on
anything other than the lyra so you
couldn't withdraw in dollars or you know
any other currency
and to me it was just like wait a minute
if you're sitting there and you
understand you know any piece of this
the red
light's got to be going off saying wait
they're locking me in the currency and
they're doing it intentionally right yep
trust me they know that
through and through that that was
exactly the reaction that they
for the first time they really realized
they had no other options outside of
bitcoin
like that is when it dawned on a lot of
people and that's why you know major
um out news outlets like in maya dean
finally started
covering bitcoin i remember flipping on
you know the tv
when i was visiting my family uh you
know mainstream arabic tv news and
seeing
the bitcoin logo behind the news anchor
and i remember thinking that was the
moment i have never been more bullish on
bitcoin
i remember thinking like this this is
absolutely the future
yeah and so like what does somebody on
the ground in lebanon do right you
mentioned that they kind of understand
the problems they know that
uh their services out there obviously
your family and
friends can reach out to you and say hey
you know direct me to what really are
kind of more obscure
platforms they don't have the marketing
budgets to kind of reach people
like let's say a coin base or some of
the other international things to do
like what are they doing are they
literally just trying to find anyone who
can give them some information
are they kind of out of luck like what
happens
yeah that's precisely it they're
scrambling for information they're
seeing you know
who are friends in different countries i
can send them
you know they can pay them with whatever
u.s dollars they have and get bitcoin in
return
it's very um you know ephemeral and kind
of brute force
it feels like they're brute forcing the
con the conversion of
you know their fiat currency like the
lira to to bitcoin
and you know frankly for a lot of folks
that don't even have
much in savings it's tough to
you know even think about
converting to bitcoin when they're you
know trying to figure out how to put
food on the table right or they can't
even hold on to anything to save in
order to convert and that's a whole
other issue as well
yeah it's really interesting that you
noticed um it's almost like uh
in the united states the you know take
the media as an example
on obviously over generalization but uh
bitcoin's this
awesome thing that you can poke every
once in a while it has tons of social
engagement by all the people who are
fanatical about it
uh but it's kind of the butt of the joke
right it's like oh that's that bitcoin
thing
um but in a country like lebanon as soon
as the currency starts to fail
everyone looks around the room realizes
the value and then you literally get the
news actually
like it sounds like not maybe not
promoting it but trying to educate
people trying to help protect
absolutely right i think that's very
different
than the way it's treated here by the
media and some of that's just
you know the dollar works pretty good
for you know majority of people
yeah absolutely i mean any any problem
that you're distance from doesn't seem
as serious
until you're experiencing it and i think
that's
exactly the case with what's going on
with you know their actual currency
um if it's primarily speculative here
and
a lot of people view it similar to
buying a share on robin hood then that's
how they're going to treat it
um but you know for a lot of folks
around the world i mean not just lebanon
latin america
plays in africa um you know uh iran like
this is this is life or death this is
savings this is food on the table for
them so
um it's certainly not a joke uh or you
know
speculation for a lot of people the
reality is just a lot different and i
think that's what a lot of people don't
understand when they say well i don't
get why we need bitcoin and you know
they're sitting in the us with you know
us dollars and
a lot of debts are of course generated
us dollars around the world and they're
unable to pay with their own currency
and it's like
you know it probably wasn't it's not
frankly it's not designed for you
exactly and it's not to say that there
aren't
many underbanked folks i think in new
york the stat was actually pretty
astonishing it was like in new york city
a third
um or something or you know roughly if
people are under banked and you know the
gra
the the center of gravity there is
around the bronx i believe but
um you know for people that just don't
get it and will always be a speculation
that's fine
this is more of a grassroots movement
and i think that we aren't used to
currency directives coming
from the bottom left we've only ever
seen them from the top down and this
time
it looks like it's going to be different
yeah and last question on
on lebanon i think this is true for
every country um
if the lebanese government came out with
another currency
do you think your parents or friends or
people you know
would trust that new currency or do you
feel like it's a kind of a one-shot deal
where
hey you had a currency you screwed it up
i don't care what you bring up next
like we don't trust you as the owner or
controller of the currency
yeah they would absolutely not trust it
uh if
i mean if they're forced to use it
they're going to use it um but at this
point i
i do believe um just based anecdotally
on what i've seen
uh bitcoin has usd of course
the greenback is the one that everybody
wants to get but bitcoin is
as now the next best thing yeah it's
it's just so
um interesting to me because i think
bitcoin actually falls in the same
category of like
uh everyone trusts the sovereign nation
that
uh is in control of the currency that
they use and everything is denominated
in
if that sovereign nation screws it up
then like they go look elsewhere and
they won't trust whatever comes next
but actually bitcoin from a currency
standpoint feels similar in that
we get kind of one shot to separate
state and money uh
and if for some reason bitcoin was to
fail do it something technical or
whatever
i always wonder would people kind of
write off the idea of separation of
state and money right like
and we don't know obviously but but it's
just something it's a really interesting
kind of mental
uh exercise to go through yeah i mean
historically looking at
you know the digital currency attempts
that came before bitcoin
i actually received significant adoption
i believe eagle was probably like
the most popular and just because it was
shut down
didn't necessarily um you know
based on bitcoin existing obviously
didn't cause any irreversible damage
um it does feel like it's a one-shot
type thing especially based on the
momentum we had
uh we have but here's the thing is
similar to how
you know they say like science advances
one death at a time
um the thing is generations forget and
so uh you know
our i'm long bitcoin most people are i
don't think it's a one-shot type deal
though
i do think that you know over time if
something is supposed to happen and the
tailwinds are there for it to happen
you know you'll figure out a way but i'm
an optimist in that regard absolutely
i want to finish up talking about uh
kind of consolidation
and mergers and acquisitions in the
crypto space uh maybe talk a little just
about
what you guys are seeing there you
talked earlier about some of the larger
companies having to raise these
emergency
rounds of funding obviously if they
can't get that the next best thing is to
figure out you know who can we go buddy
up with
but just kind of what are you guys
seeing in that space around mna
right so um you token data actually had
an excellent report on this and it's
i mean as of end of last year there have
been three 350 acquisitions
today in the crypto space and worth 4
billion in value which was yeah
surprising to me as well i didn't
realize it was that big um but
you know in terms of being in more of a
bearish market
you generally see horizontal mergers
right these are usually used to acquire
talent or technology or licensing
but in bull markets you see more
financial m a happening and these are
companies that
you know can be vertically integrated
and required based on their returns as
opposed to
you know talent tech or licensing so
we're seeing more horizontal
m a right now which is indicative of you
know what market appetite is like but
do you think it's going to uh improve uh
you know just historically on how
bitcoin has moved in the next um
you know 12 to 15 months so it sounds
like one of the
uh kind of obstacles or friction points
is actually just the balance sheets
of companies that would be the acquirer
right there's only so many companies
that can actually
have enough money to acquire given um
it's relatively small but
i would never have guessed 350 plus
acquisitions that's a very high number
right yeah absolutely we do see
you do see like you know uh these bigger
exchanges driving a lot of them
um but uh you know we'll see
where this ends up going i think there
have been a few attempts that
decentralized mna which i do think is
almost nonsensical if not
counterintuitive because if it
is a decentralized project there should
be nothing which can be acquired
or merged perhaps merged but certainly
not acquired
um but you know they've been watched as
in the case of
steam recently but i do foresee as
having a few horizontal
mergers based on how the market goes
maybe a few more than a few
um but once we're in a bull market
you'll probably know because we'll see a
lot more of these
financial m a's happening and i guess uh
so decentralization i'm in complete
agreement there that that's kind of
an oxymoron but uh do you feel like
we'll start to see
um kind of acquisitions or mergers of
networks so maybe they're not actually
decentralized but do you feel like we'll
see
networks actually coming together in
some way or even
centralized corporations that are
for-profit kind of you know traditional
private companies
trying to acquire some of the networks
yeah i guess that would look like
something similar to oh i don't know
microsoft requirement github um you know
something
akin to that could probably happen uh of
course
you'd probably lose a lot of uh you know
ardent followers
in the network especially if it was
under the pretext of it being
decentralized um people never fail to
find ways to surprise you so i
wouldn't rule it out i love that that's
a good perspective to have
i finished up each interview with the
same two questions
the first one is what is the most
important book that you've ever read
the most important book i've ever read
is definitely colored by recency bias
but space barons
it's about bezos and
musk's journey to colonize space
and you know of course there's a lot of
uh symmetry or you know a lot of
metaphors that people make about us
mooning and us
you know um we have a lot of uh
metaphors that are in common with like i
love space
stuff but just the the story behind
why they started their companies and the
sheer resourcefulness
that they had to each do in order to
one afford to build space companies to
do a serious upheaval
of a um uh you know a sector that would
that had you know incumbents that were
you know giving kickbacks to
former employees to start companies that
were zombies and kept them afloat
in order to break that up and you know
allow the private sector a chance to
compete in space
is so inspiring and i think that every
person in crypto should read it because
you see this in finance you see some
education see some help
you see this across industries where
people are trying to fundamentally
move something from the ground up and uh
it's been the most inspiring book i've
read so far yeah i haven't even heard of
that so i'll definitely go read that
um the other one is uh much more fun and
actually related to space
aliens believer or non-believer
like i said you'll never fail to be
surprised believer
and i think it was actually in fact
verified right didn't they say there
were ufos or something
earlier this year in the middle of coba
and everyone's like yeah aliens sure why
not
at this point bring more away so it's
even
scarier than that so the ufo thing when
i saw it
at first i didn't understand why no one
was freaking out and then i guess that
the videos had already leaked on reddit
and stuff like years ago
yeah yeah and this was just kind of
confirming it but
uh the one that i saw recently uh that
just
you know you kind of look around the
room and you're like am i the only
person reading this is
i think a year or two ago uh they
found a i'll call it a radio signal i
don't know what the right scientific
terminology is
uh but it was repeating on like a 16-day
pattern so every 16 days they were
getting this signal
that they were getting from you know
deep space whatever that means
uh and so just recently they discovered
a
second one that is repeating every 157
days
and so you sit there and like i got a
lot of questions right like what
technology are we using how do you know
it's real
like whatever all the the normal
questions you would have but when you
start to
think through this you're like all right
maybe there is uh an improvement in
technology that we've had where like
you know we're just now able to detect
things in space that we previously
weren't able to but they're
going to be explained in some natural
phenomenon you know in the future
but like if we find enough radio signals
like you're telling me none of them
are going to be alien like come on if we
find 1000 of them
right it's kind of like planets uh were
in school
there was nine planets like when i was
in elementary right there was nine
planets right
there did pluto dirty well now there's
over i think over a
thousand planets that they've identified
and you're like
you're telling me that on a thousand
there's not life
maybe but yeah i like our odds of
finding something i guess
absolutely yeah no that's i mean there
have been you know many paradoxes being
after this
it's um i do think it's incredibly it'd
be
it's more unlikely that there isn't any
other life form um and you know why not
throw in daughter universes and
metaverses
while we're at it yeah no space is
severely underexplored i'm really
excited i think that
musk and bezos made space like cool
again it's cool to watch rocket launches
again
and i'm really optimistic about where
space is going to go if you want to go
down a rabbit hole that will uh will
leave your head spinning
uh if you google two galaxies colliding
right now supposedly somewhere in the
you know millions of miles away there
are two galaxies that are colliding
and as you read the articles it will
then say in like two or four billion
years our galaxy's gonna collide with
this new one
and you start to like man we really
don't matter
right like we are so inconsequential to
this place
i don't even know how we know that
galaxies are colliding what that means
or anything
but uh but but it's pretty a humbling
frankly right
really is quite the pale blue dot uh
you uh you could ask me one question to
uh to end this what uh what question do
you have for me
are you an alien
[Laughter]
no i'm kidding um
you know it's generic but i do like to
see how people's thoughts evolve
so i like to ask it over time it's not
necessarily the one answer i like to
see how people's thoughts fall over time
so yeah what are you most excited about
in crypto um
my thoughts on this have definitely
changed over time uh
i've become much boring over time and
the answer without a doubt emphatically
is bitcoin
but i think the reason why is what has
like changed my understanding of it and
um
the thing that i am now absolutely
convinced of
is the separation of state and money is
uh one important but it has this ripple
effect across so many aspects of our
life
right you were saying earlier um about
kind of the the quote-unquote crime
of devaluing money and kind of all of
the impacts of that
and as you learn i think more like
not only what is money but why is money
structured the way that it is
you begin to realize marty ben's got a
great line he says uh
fix the money fix the world right and
and it's kind of like this core unit of
account if you can go at that and you
can drastically improve it
you actually can create a much more fair
equitable world
and so people give me [ __ ] when i say it
but like if that happens and again it's
an if right i think you and i are
convinced it will happen but but it's an
if
uh i actually think that bitcoin will do
more to create that fair and equitable
world than all like philanthropy
combined
right and so when you start to like
think of things like that you're like
that sounds crazy unless you've spent
way too many hours to admit like
thinking about this stuff learning about
it whatever
but the level of importance of a thing
that even has the
you know 0.1 chance of doing that is
just so
undervalued right and so one of the
things i started to think more and more
about is like
actually if you take the most bullish
people in bitcoin
they're likely to be underestimating
what's possible here
right and so when you start thinking
about that it's like that's pretty cool
right i think that's true that's a great
answer
absolutely i've only had a couple
hundred uh opportunities to uh say it
a little practice don't give me too much
where can we send people to uh to learn
more about you uh
token daily and volt capital yeah so
you know the token daily twitter account
t-o-k-e-n
daily my twitter account sooner or later
s-o-o-n-a
or later and also just drop me a line at
my email address which is tsuna
volt.capital awesome that twitter
account is a
that's a pretty good name there thanks
yeah it's quite the vanity handle i love
it all right soon thank you so much for
doing this i'll do it again in the
future
yep definitely thanks for having me